this is you you grew up in neighborhood
where nobody spoke candy english from primary school's college
the eternal themes of your english
classes were grammar teaching drills and tests
you are not encouraged to speak the language
that much in ninety percent of your class
time was been talking about english in chinese
although you did try to read a booking english
do you smash the book after three pages
then beating itself
your tongue was always tied up in the
prisons of a foreigner and in front of the
examiners that was why your transcript to see you again
what is the secret of language
acquisition is grammar learning
truly the center of language
proficiency as we're told for years
where is it something else for people without a language
rich environment
what is the best way out of this
what is up guys of shy lynne here
the language enthusiast in a curious person
as an undergradust ra university
point five in the ttest
and a brown's metal in the flt
rp cop of the speaking contest
i also attended a master finest program
taught english as shanghai jin university
and by the way
i certainly speak with an accent
and make mistakes from time to time
would like to beg for your mercy
whenever you spot by mistakes
这个视频基于南加州大学的语言学权威
dr iph郑教授数10年的研究
而我个人的经历
几乎完美的印证了他所有的观点
视频所涉及的内容可以浓缩为下面三点
第一
获得流利外语能力的唯一途径
是大量的精度输入
可理解i加一的输入材料
材料越有趣
第三自由消遣阅读
free voluntary reading
是提升语言能力最长效
最自主也是最快乐的途径
如果你想要立刻获得实际的建议
你可以直接快进到
这个视频的最后两个部分
但是相信我
如果你看完全片的话
并且不止一次让我们进入第一部分
首先是这个视频的终极问题
我们是如何掌握一门语言的
就这个问题
有两个学术流派争论了几十年至今
低派是可理解输入假说
comprehensible input hypothesis
他们认为我们的外语能力
来源于大量的听读输入
并且当我们能够理解输入的信息的时候
given messages
people understand what we call comprehensible input language
acquisition will take it happened subconsciously
automatically and inevitably
我们应该及时行乐
从简单有趣的图书漫画音频开始输入
我们的大脑将会自动建立起词汇
语法句式的长期记忆
也就是说理解输入带来语言技能
skilling hypotheses
他们认为我们要先苦后甜
先要经过漫长的记单词
背句式
学语法
我们才能够开始读懂文字
听懂对话
也就是说语言技能带来理解输入
两个假说在因果关系上是对立的
顺便说一句
对于99%的公众而言
而是一条真理
是从古至今的传统
先学语法
通过考试
还有一天
总有一天我们就可以开口流利地讲外语了
只不过对于大部分人来说
这一天从来就没有到来罢了
not a single person on this planet
has ever acquired language
or develop literacy
using skill building
when someone says
my cousin learned to
when you look at the case
closely
you see lots and lots of comprehensible input
过去30年间
可理解输入假说获得了压倒性的学术研究
证据支持
不只是失败了一次
他几乎从来就没有奏效过
da question认为
当一个成年人流利运用外语的时候
其95%的外语能力
都来源于可理解输入
对于小
孩子来说这个数字可能是百分之百
让我们来看一个很有趣的案例研究
而mango是一个墨西哥裔的小伙子
他在洛杉矶郊区的一家以色列餐馆
打工多年
当他和母语者对话的时候
对方多半会认为
或者至少相差无几
他说他只是在餐馆里面和人们聊天
从前12年只会零星的几个单词
到逐渐流利研究
怎么又问
你知道这句话是过去式那个动词
你为什么要这样变
味吗
而豌豆回答说
i have a slightest idea of those rules
这不就是你班上英语最好的那两个孩子吗
当你焦头烂额的分析完形填空题目的时候
他们总是能够读一遍就把正确答案选出来
当你去问他们的时候
他们会跟你说
类似于干我作证
他们不是装高手
可能是真的说不出来
并且这一点也不罕见
任何一个孩子成长到十岁的时候
已经可以流利的语法
准确地使用自己的母语
而此时他们可能还没有上过一节语法课
也不知道什么叫做主谓宾
此外十岁孩子的词汇量平均在2万个左右
这是大部
and this is by no means
twenty thousand trips to the dictionary
and it has to come from a lot of input
这些案例告诉我们
语法知识并不是流利运用语言的前提
实际上在对话中有意识地运用语法知识
理论上是不可能的
the rule doesn't
he在这个简单的反问句里面
由主语替换
动词替换
肯定否定
置换语序
调换发音语调等等各种各样的规则
而当你试图用语法拼完一句话的时候
你的对话伙伴人都没了
更别说还有人尽皆知的三单规则上
and nose
当句子中的主语是三单的时候
动词末尾要加s或者非规则
变形
很多人可能重复记忆了这条规则数百次
但每一次开口还是会毫无意外的犯错
比如说成he know the rule
如果你是的话
请打一自然顺序假说
natural road
害怕此事为
从现在进行时开始到复数形式
到be动词等等
理论上是不可能的
而三单这个看似简单的规则
其实在自然顺序的晚期
大多数的英语教学体系
因此即便你可以背出这条规则
你也不会
用它
不过请一定不要误会我
语法能力非常重要
在口语和写作中运用准确丰富的语法结构
是高等级语言能力的标志之一
但是我们想说的是
先记忆语法
这个被广为接受的内化假说
internalization
已经被40年来的大量研究所证伪
我再重复一遍
这就好像说
一个游泳运动员
九成以上的能力都来自于海量训练中
而如果只通过别人给你讲书里
你将永远也学不会游泳
ta knowledge is knowledge
we often teach explicit rules for things
but some
and could not be taught just by telling rules of
how to do this thing
一部分的语言知识
可以被写成规则和教科书
这被称作显性知识
explicit n
但其绝大部分都是一种以视之是pass
noch
what we're now saying is
if we give people messages that are
interesting and comprehensible grammar to a large
extent care itself
我们在此声明
如果你真的很喜欢语法
就像我一样没有问题
但是请记住输入为主
语法为辅
if you want to do grammar find browse grammar a minute
two minutes etc
ninety nine
percent of your focus should be uncomprehensible input
those are things you hear
or things you read
在我们积累了大量的输入
可以相对流利的讲话之后
并且将其使用在书面
写作等时间充裕的场合
将最终让你的语言技能
语法知识更加熟练
如果说一个人学了10年
2000个小时的传统英语课程
而他花费了90%的时间在技能学
那么真正的可理解输入就只有区区两
再看一看你的教材
这是the natural pro
去书里面对19世纪语言教科书的描述
至今仍然适用
教科书
编撰者们沉迷于把一门外语编码
称为晦涩难懂的各种规则
再拿给学生们死记硬背
口头交流
所剩无几
仅有的一点点例子被放在书末
作为某种附录
而且这些例子往往又困难又枯燥
我手边的这本日语教材
就是同类中最好的之一
但即便如此
任何一课的12页内容里面
只有半页是有趣的
可理解输入
其余的内容都是单词表
语法解释
根据刚才的理论
这样的结构没有一点可能
让我流利的运用语言
那么在这样的情况下
我们很有可能逃出生天吗
当然可以
只要找到好的输入材料
你就可以改变自己的命运
你再重复一遍
只要能够找到最优的输入材料
你就可以改变自己的命运
这是加拿大多余者steve cofman
他通过自学熟练掌握了16门外语
而他是这么说的
content is king grammar explanations
dictionaries
ankees game
none of that matters in
my opinion is secondary
the key thing is the availability of meaningful content
in the language
输入为王
而最好的输入材料需要满足三个条件
第一可理解comprehensible
或者叫做循序渐进
a加1a就是你目前的水平
恰好在你的水平上面一点点
如果太难输入
就会变成噪音和折磨
比如说你完全听不懂的外语广播
第二是要有趣情绪机制
甲说告诉我们说
有趣的材料
可以最大程度降低人的压力水平
过滤网
affect filter
而使人获得更多的收入
反之无趣或者困难的材料
会让情绪过滤网变成情绪强
可能会导致你一个字都输入不进去
第三要足量
sufficient quantity
研究表明
11个小时的可理解输入
已经可以让成年人开口讲话
但是要成为流利的使用者
你需要成百上千个小时的输入
多年来
我们遇到过很多可以理解
但是无趣的输入
我们一般称之为英语教材
也有有趣
但是因为难度过高而不可理解的输入
整个音乐世界
同时很多人尽其一生努力给学生们
开发者又不可理解又无趣的输入
我们一般称之为英语试卷
而我们想要的是既有趣又可理解的输入
有一个完美的例子就是漫画书comebox
大量的图画和精彩的故事
使得漫画说
天然具有极佳的可理解性和趣味性
还有b站上就可以找到的
english pod和e s l盘
这些材料
把大量的与会融入爆笑的故事里面
烟台循序渐进
适合初学者
而如果一种材料是如此有趣
以至于使用者会暂时忘记这些外语写成的
我们说这种输入扣人心弦
compelling input
当使用compelling input的时候
我们会进入心理学家
mhy childm hii所说的心流状态flow
此时我们完全沉浸在阅读故事的快乐之中
听起来很科幻吗
但是达到这种状态
其实比你想象的更加容易
我们所知最有可能找到compelling input的地方
就是阅读
而且我们说的是自由自愿阅读
所以voluntary reading俗称读闲书
在上课时
你在桌下读的漫画书
你熬到凌晨也不愿放下的小说
也就是说你因为兴趣而进行的任何阅读
doctor在他的书the power of reading里面这样总结
他们可以持续的增强自己的外语能力
无需课堂
无需老师
如果你不相信的话
这里有个很震撼的案例研究
karen是一位34岁的韩国女士
她在美国生活了5年
但是英语能力非常有限
他尝试过一次英文原著阅读
但是很快受挫而放弃了
因为他说他在查词典上所花的时间
比阅读本身还要多
并且仍然不知道书里到底在说些什么
彼此彼此像极了
你第一次读原著的样子
你会找出来一本呼啸山庄worthy h
然后把前三页写满
各种各样的单词
是义和笔记
之后的几百页则光亮如新
如果正式雨的话
请打一
研究者们建议karen从sweet valley high开始阅读
这是一套小学6年级水平的英文小说
对他来说太难了
于是他们降低到了sweet valley twins
从系列4年级水平的小说还是太难了
直到最后降低到sweet dady kids 2年级水平
这下karen可以读懂了
而让人震惊的是
karen成为了sweet daily系列的狂热读者
在短短1年的时间里面
他读完了66本这个系列的小说
并且自愿开始阅读更高难度的
通俗小说和各种杂志
他的阅读能力和词汇量发生了飞跃
而他对此甚至毫无意识
nobody knows how this feels better than me
这是我高三时候的雅思成绩单
你能看到我的口语得到了七分还不错
但是写作是不合格的
5.5分
总体而言
6.5分的总分也完全不算出彩
高三暑假
我决定开始用英语读闲书
像karen一样
我从一套2年级水平的儿童读物
魔法树屋magic tree house开始读
这是两个孩子在一间树屋中的冒险故事
而他们正是我完美的a加一输入
因为我只需要偶尔查记一个单词
就可以理解大部分的故事
我完全被这些故事迷住了
我连读了20多本魔法书
然后读了十多本sein sheldon的悬疑小说
然后是各种学术资料的阅读
我的阅读经历几乎完美的符合
dr的阅读阶梯理论
condi hypotheses
及人的阅读能力发展经历三个阶段
首先是很多很多很多的故事
漫画书
儿童图书小说
然后是自由自愿的消遣阅读
最后是高等级的学术文献阅读
在快乐的读了2年书之后
我收到了第二份雅思成绩单
让人吃惊的是
我的总分提升了整整3%
到了8.5分
总分九分
更有趣的是
我的两项输出能力
口语和写作
分别提升了21%和36%
到了8.5分和7.5分
这是因为读贤书带来的大量主动与会
是听说读写四项能力的共同从基础
我没有进行脱产备考
更没有背过单词
但阅读的语境和重复
使得我想不记住各种理亏都不可能
但此时你的感受将会是四个字
水到渠成
three voluntary reading
which is a very pleasant
form of comprehensible input
it's the source of our reading
comprehension much of our educated vocabulary
nearly all of it
our ability to write with good
writing
styles to write and read and understand complex
dramatical constructions
and this seems to be true across languages
实际上30多年来的大量研究表明
自由自由阅读是提升英语能力的最佳途径
对于标准化考试而言尤其如此
本ino mason的研究显示
每个小时的自由阅读
这意味着
如果你每天阅读一个半小时的援助
差不多2年之后就可以从中低水准
一路增长到最高水平
并且不学语法
不练写作
相比于传统备考课程
每小时00:27左右的提升
自由阅读的效率是后者的三倍
转换为老托福考试之后
自由阅读的效率
仍然是传统备考课程的两倍左右
也就是说
如果你一整年都用来读原著
上课不花一分钱
反而能获得两三倍的效果
并且这一切发生的同时
你只是在读小说而已
当你沉浸在读英文贤书的快乐之中时
结果却是不断增长的词汇量
准确的语法能力和熟练的写作技巧
而这一切将自然发生
无可避免
在comprehensible input面前
工具和方法都是次要的
请在互联网的帮助之下
从今天开始去寻找自己的儿童图书
如果一个故事读不懂或者不够有趣
你应该立刻放下她
去找更简单更有趣的故事
找到之后只需要享受一个好故事
我们从未说过
但是任何人都应该谨记
输入为主
语法为辅
沿着可理解输入之路
我从完全缺乏英语的环境中走出来
顶着老师的日常训斥
如果小艾丽在有没听见李九的国人
还不得了吗
从魔法树屋去到了广阔的英语事件
走到了雅思总分8.5
而我还将继续沿着这条路走向下一门语言
这个视频我前后做了三个多月
研究了大量文献
修改了十余次文案
只求他在有趣的同时能够启发你
开始接受可理解输入
作为一个选择少年的我
因为幸运和很多的帮助而走上了一条正道
对此我无比感激
所以我也真心的希望这个视频可以让更多
的人知晓
you have a chance
just like i did anthology
takes is a good story book
如果这个视频让你得到一点启发
欢迎你将它传播下去
也请不要忘记关注我和给我三连
鼓励我继续创作这样的内容
下面的这些问题
虽然已经得到了部分的回答
但是如果大家想听某个问题的深入讨论
可以把问题的号码打在弹幕里面
同时我的兴趣也远远不只是语言
我会对很多有趣的问题
都用同样系统的方法进行研究
当然这需要大量的时间
所以说希望大家关注我
并且给我支持和耐心
非常感谢大家
我们下次再见